tell us what's happening in ukraine with
air drops
so the ukraine has said from their
official twitter account that they're
actually going to airdrop um either nfts
or tokens it's very unclear what they
meant by this but they're actually going
to airdrop people who donated
cryptocurrencies uh or cryptocurrency to
the ukraine they're going to airdrop you
something basically so they now have
your wallet now they have the ability to
kind of airdrop and this speaks to the
technology of bitcoin and what's going
on um so before the airdrop they
received about 33 million dollars worth
of donations you can see here the listed
addresses for bitcoin ethereum and usdt
they have since added i believe polka
dot um to this based off of gavin wood
who is the creator of polka dot he was
like hey please add it i'll donate a lot
but so 14 million has already been
distributed based off the 33 million
that they got before the announcement of
the airdrop but then since the
announcement of this airdrop they
actually got another around seven
million dollars worth of crypto a lot of
that was from one polka dot donation but
they got another seven million dollars
of crypto and they can actually airdrop
it and 14 million has been
uh
dispersed is what you'll call it um but
yeah you can see that they they went
ahead and added this um yesterday and uh
you can see they just put up their polka
dot address and the people of ukraine
fighting for our freedom are forever
grateful to gavin wood um for the
generous donation he is i believe the
founder of um polkadot but he donated 5
million polka dot so it's nice to see
that no matter where it is um if you
post a polka dot address i'll personally
contribute 5 million bucks so i don't
know how or what or maybe just being a
super good guy wanted kind of exposure
polka dot count this is a marketing
expense whatever it is um it's cool to
see that he donated 5 million to ukraine
i'm interested to see how they kind of
disperse this and like are they
converting everything to a certain
currency and then sending that out based
on um based on these wallets or based on
like usd whatever it is um but it's cool
to see how many donations that they've
gotten what do you think about the rapid
increase in hey we can
send payments very very easily to this
one address and then they can kind of
disperse it how they see fit is ukraine
doing a gofundme for war
i think not for war but i think
essentially
is that what it boils down to doing a
little gofundme for war uh i think it's
cool again right to be to see that it's
being used on the stage uh i think
people are are either slightly confused
or curious how it's going to make a
difference on on a on a level where
you're getting four or 500 million
dollars from a country and then you get
five or 15 20 million dollars in crypto
donations obviously it's important any
kind of amount of money you can do to
support and show that uh you're with the
people of ukraine as they stand in
defense and try to defend their country
uh their families their land etc but i
think uh it's interesting to see like
how this is going to be used right is
this something like what are they air
dropping
what are they air dropping are they are
dropping nfts are they air dropping
something else tokens that have like
monetary value it's very very unclear
yeah i i don't i don't know so i think
uh most people probably donated it with
the expectation that they wouldn't get
anything in return just like uh hey uh
i've been in crypto i own crypto i have
some extra crypto like here you go uh we
want to stand and support you we we
believe in you we want uh to see the
people uh in ukraine be free and do all
these things so maybe that's one part of
it
but i think this there's still a lot to
be settled here of like what this
actually turns out to be but what do you
think about the idea that they can
basically post an address on twitter um
and quickly fund 30 to 40 million
dollars
within within three to like three to
five days i mean to be fair you could do
that in in us dollars right you could
start a gofundme and you can go and
contribute us dollars and uh say that i
think that the other part is like a lot
of people complain and someone's saying
this in the chat of like
people complain when u.s dollars the
government prints up to money they go
spending on war and nothing happens and
and whatever right so if you take what
happened in afghanistan right we were
there for uh 20 years and we flee and
basically leave it in the exact same
hands that we got there in 20 years ago
we wasted trillions and trillions of
dollars of money that was printed that
hurt our citizens right because you're
uh you're raising the level of inflation
you're creating money uh you you're not
only creating money but you're giving it
out and putting in regions of the world
that aren't within the united states so
there's some kind of uh velocity of
money that's created outside which is
which is different as well but
ultimately i think part of it is uh one
people are able to make these decisions
so it's not necessarily the government
so sure there's some kind of level of
you're voting for the politicians and
the people that are in charge of these
decisions and they go end up in
ultimately doing that but people are
people are doing this with their own
money right they're saying hey this is
money that i control this is currency
that i control and i'm providing it to
you if i want to so i think that's one
main difference and then the other one
is like
you're you're doing it as a donation to
ukraine right i don't think you're
funding it as hey go go i'm pro-war i go
start a war i don't want you to go uh uh
buy fighter jets and start attacking
other countries right i think people are
donating it to ukraine as a way to help
them defend themselves and we've seen
other countries do that right they're
saying uh we don't want to necessarily
get involved from a military aspect of
delivering troops there dropping troops
off and having to help them defend you
uh because of all the other things that
come when you fight russia right they
have nuclear weapons they've already
publicly started to hint that they may
use those if the time came and certain
things started to happen which is which
is scary in its own right but i think
the the biggest difference is that it's
up to people's personal opinion right
they have the uh the ability to uh or
personal decisions they have the ability
to donate if they want to and uh if
you're okay using that to give to a
country that you think will do it in the
right way and fund it for and use those
funds for defense and other things then
do it and if you're not then don't but
ultimately it's not up to the government
right these are personal funds people
are using within crypto that own crypto
uh so i think that's probably the major
difference in my mind hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time